JJ wrote in David how should we evaluate
the economy it seems like I can always
find someone saying things are great and
someone else saying things are awful and
I don't know enough about economics to
know who's right do you have any advice
or recommendations for how to analyze
the economy and know when things are
doing well and more importantly how do
we know what's causing the economy to do
well or poorly how do we separate
correlation and causation Wow
these are very very good questions and
not questions with a simple answer I
think that the political underpinnings
of what you're saying is you will see
the stock market do well or not do well
and you'll see people say on that basis
that the economy is doing well or that
it's not doing well and then the second
layer of that is saying well even if the
stock market is doing well it's not
because of anything the President did or
even if the stock market is doing poorly
it's not because of anything the
President did if you want to defend a
president you can look at unemployment
rates you can look at job creation you
can look at inflation consumer
confidence index trade balance the
answer is sadly as with most areas of
economics there actually is no one
indicator that you can look at to
determine how the economy is doing the
stock market can give you a sense as to
the perceived value of investors of
companies that are publicly traded but
of course those values can become those
share prices can become overvalued they
can also reflect the deliberate sort of
ignoring of economic realities that are
going on in other parts of the economy
and remember the overwhelming majority
of stock ownership is highly highly
concentrated so whether the economy is
doing well or not at large
only slightly relates to how the stock
market is doing you can look at
unemployment for example problem with
unemployment is that number one when you
stop looking for work you're no longer
considered unemployed this is just a
reality has nothing to do with Democrats
or Republicans in the White House that's
how it's always been measured that is
often manipulated for political purposes
additionally the unemployment rate
doesn't tell you
what is happening with wages we've had a
very very long period of wage stagnation
in the United States you can take a look
at something like the Consumer Price
Index which tells us about inflation but
of course different levels of inflation
represent either a concern or a non
concern depending on what other factors
are going on so there's really no one
indicator you can look at and that's why
it really requires more in-depth
thinking you should consider
unemployment jobs created job quality
change in wages the impact of the stock
market on things like retirement
accounts because that dictates a lot of
whether people approaching retirement
age are able to afford to retire you can
look at things like trade balance Trump
doesn't really seem to understand it he
just throws out we lose on trade we went
on trade whatever there is really no one
indicator and there aren't even really
specific numbers it's not like well if
inflation is up 4% but the stock market
is up 10% then it's okay that there's
really just nothing like that and this
is something that really requires a lot
of thought and nuance and it's not
something you're really ever going to
get from corporate media sadly I think
house ownership rates is a good metric
though because that's really like a
middle-class metric it seems like the
American Dream here is to be able to
work hard enough so that one day you'll
be able to afford your own home but then
again I think a lot of people are living
in cities nowadays you see a lot more
renters they're really just is no one
perfect metric out I actually forgot to
mention homeownership rate but yeah and
homeownership rates can go up or down
not only based on real estate prices but
also based on mortgage rates which
connects to Federal Reserve policy so
again important but it doesn't tell us
everything that we need to know so I
think that the best thing I can tell you
is to learn about all of the different
indicators and really try to take a more
sort of holistic approach to analyzing
how the economy is doing you're not
going to get it from corporate media
that's for sure so you're going to need
to recur to other sources